et
si l'autre avait raison
même quand je pense qu'il a tort
ça vous est jamais arrivé d'être
convaincus d'un point de vue
et la force de discussions
finissiez par changer d'avis tout
simplement parce que votre première idée
ne fait plus sens
moi ça m'arrive très souvent et je suis
très heureuse de vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui je le vis bien
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas
pendant les trente premières années de
ma vie j'avais l'impression de devoir me
battre pour faire valoir mon point de
vue
j'avais l'impression aussi dans un autre
cas de céder au point de vue de l'autre
avec cette sensation vous savez un peu
amer d'avoir comme perdu la bataille
mais dans aucun des cas j'étais à l'aise
alors ce que je vous propose là
maintenant
c'est d'enlever ce marteau du juge
de retirer cette analyse qui se
demandent avec la tête qu'est ce qui est
bien qu est ce qui est mal qui a tort
qui a raison
qui est le meilleur
de déposer ce marteau juste à côté la
doter cette posture de juges en faveur
d'une posture d'accueil
l'accueil de ceux qui de vous deux mois
des êtres humains
d'être dans notre similarités dans notre
équivalence
voilà de vous parler de carragher
alors ceci est en pause et je vais vous
présenter comment faire lorsqu'une
personne est différente de nous pour
quand même se sentir en paix
mieux encore comment faire pour
participer à ce qu' elle aussi elle se
sentant pas malgré notre différence
est ainsi paré fait brillamment
participé à un monde
qui soit quelque part avait plus
accueillants secure en sam
alors pour vous expliquer cela je vais
revenir sur ces fameuses trente
premières années de ma vie comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure j'étais
beaucoup beaucoup dans la tête à me
demander qu'est ce qui est bien et ce
qui est mal c'était totalement
inconsciente bien entendu c'était mon
éducation d'ailleurs peut-être que vous
remarquerez que chez vous vous avez reçu
à peu près le même type de d'éducation
je vous invite à vérifier quoi qu'il en
soit chez moi c'était ça je vérifier
chez moi un est ce que c'est bien ce que
c'est mal chez l'autre vraiment et
j'étais dans le jugement perpétuelle est
en réalité j'en souffrais énormément
pourquoi et bien parce que nous n'avons
pas tous la même conception du bien et
du mal oui on n'a pas les mêmes cadres
de référence on n'a pas les mêmes
préférences
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui explique que
l'on n'a pas les même avis que l'on fait
des choix parfois qu'ils s'opposent
et que ce soit dans tous les vecteurs de
la ville dans la famille avec les amis
au travail dans la vie amoureuse
et dans la société regardez avec la
crise du coc vide
certains considèrent qui devrait être
obligatoire de porter le masque et de se
faire vacciner
tout simplement pour pouvoir enrayer la
pandémie et prendre soin de la santé du
peuple
là où d'autres considèrent que au
contraire ça ne devrait pas être
obligatoire de porter le masque est de
se faire vacciner
et ce dans le but de respecter la
liberté de tous la singularité
est également l'intégrité physique de
chacun
un autre exemple certains considèrent
que le voit le port du voile devrait
être interdit et ce pour manifester
l'égalité entre les citoyens
et puis d'autres considèrent que non au
contraire ils veulent pouvoir porter
leur voile parce que pour eux dans leur
conviction religieuse s'est vraiment
uvrer pour le bien
un autre exemple un dernier il ya ceux
qui considèrent que la cuvette des
toilettes devrait rester élevée là où
d'autres pensent qu'elle devrait rester
baissé
on est d'accord sur tout plein de
domaines on va vivre des convergences
des divergences plus tôt et parfois des
convergences d'ailleurs
mais quoi qu'il en soit on ne peut pas
s'entendre surtout
si je reviens à mon histoire le problème
c'est que moi je le vivais mal parce
qu'en fait j'avais l'impression de vivre
des jeux de pouvoir comme ça dans toutes
mes relations quasiment toutes en tout
cas
et j'étais pas heureuse mais vraiment on
j'étais même je pourrais appeler ça un
burn-out relationnel on va inventer le
mot mais j'étais vraiment mais éreintés
fatigué et j'en suis arrivée jusqu'à la
dépression tellement ça ça
m'insupportait parce que j'avais
l'impression qu'il y avait toujours des
perdants dans l'histoire alors que moi
au plus profond de moi j'avais une envie
ses convives du gagnant gagnant entre
nous j'avais envie que chacun puisse
vivre sa pleine singularité tout en
sentant en paix et trimer à oui malgré
qu'on soit différent
et j'avais un peu l'impression d'être
seul à penser ça
donc en pleine dépression je vais à une
conférence une éternelle conférence et
puis à un moment donné sur le côté joue
un prospectus qui traînent informant
d'une formation sur la communication non
violente
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc et le
peu de mots que je vois j'ai waouh ça me
parle ça je rentre vite fait chez moi je
regarde sur internet c'est quoi et tous
les maux toutes les indications me
disent que ça ressemble aux valeurs que
je viens de vous évoquez
j'ai décidé de m'inscrire
et jeu v exactement enfin ses valeurs
mais le truc le plus formidable dans
tout ça c'était pas seulement des idées
un peu bisounours c'est que c'était
quelque chose de pratique aux pratiques
que je pouvais vraiment mettre en
application dans ma vie et qui
fonctionnait
alors je me suis formé formé forme et
j'ai adoré
salon la petite mauvaise nouvelle là
dedans c'est qu'il a fallu que je change
eh oui il a fallu que je modifie ma
façon de voir les choses et plus
particulièrement ma façon de voir
l'autre
eh oui que j'arrête d'analyser la
fameuse posture du juge que j'arrête de
juger et l'autre et moi d'ailleurs et
les situations
et que je considère qu' il y avait
peut-être une autre façon de procéder
celle que nous invite à avoir la
communication non violente qui
consistait dans une perception plus
sensorielle plus émotionnelle quelque
chose plus à l'écouté du corps en sommes
en fait c'est un formidable indicateur
de ce que l'on vit de notre humanité en
somme
c'est ce que nous ressentons nous tous
les êtres humains
alors voilà ce que je vous propose et
bien c'est de mettre de côté d'essayer
du moins de mettre de côté cette posture
du juge qui analysent au service d'une
autre posture en vous imaginant ce petit
fils
que l'on peut appeler le fils de
l'humanité
imaginez vous que ce film nous relie les
êtres humains entre nous dans cette
similarité que nous avons a simplement
ressentir des émotions et avoir tous des
besoins des besoins universel
je vous expliquerai un peu plus tard ce
qu'on va faire avec ce fil
mais avant ça j'avais envie de vous
partager un moment qui m'a vraiment
bouleversée alors comme je voulais dit
j'étais à fond je voulais apprendre la
cnv la communication non violente et je
n'arrêtais pas je n'arrêtais pas alors
je lisais aussi beaucoup et je lisais un
ouvrage de marshall rosenberg le
fondateur de la communication non
violente qui s'appelle les mots sont des
fenêtres ou sont des murs je vous le
recommande chaleureusement d'ailleurs au
passage mais alors dedans il il parle
d'une de senna des anecdotes parce qu'il
a fait beaucoup d'interventions à
l'international et il était donc à
bethléem dans un camp de réfugiés il y
avait cent soixante dix personnes
et puis à un moment donné il ya une
rumeur donc moi je lis le bouquin et il
raconte qu'il ya une rumeur qui court
dans l'assemblée et là un homme s'écrie
vous êtes un tueur d'enfants
alors là moi je vous raconte pas quand
je dis ça jubile va réagir j'étais au
tec et
la marshall qu'est ce qu'il a fait
il a répondu parce qu'en fait il était
au courant que à tout le monde en
voulait aux états unis de vendre des
armes à israël
alors il a répondu à cet homme est ce
que vous êtes en colère parce que vous
aimeriez que mon pays face à un autre
usage de ces ressources
est ce que vous aimeriez que mon pays
nous aide dans vos conditions de vie
exactement vous vos enfants ils ont des
écoles ils ont des terrains de jeu
parce que le mien d'enfants la wii joue
c'est dans les égouts
et cet homme il a continué à parler de
sa souffrance pendant 20 minutes
et marchal s'est contentée
d'écouter cet homme non pas en écoutant
qu'ils sont attaques non pas en écoutant
ces mots où il le traité d'assassin
mais en recevant chacune de ses paroles
en allant repérer les sentiments et les
besoins implicite
derrière chacune de ses déclarations
en entendant pas cela comme des attaques
mais comme le don d'un semblable qui
partage ses rancoeurs
qui partage sa vulnérabilité
et après cela cet homme il avait vu que
suffisamment d'écouté de compréhension
de respect pour être à même d'écouter ce
pourquoi marshall venait c'est à dire
partager les bienfaits de la
communication non violente
alors moi quand j'ai lu ça dans ce
bouquin waouh j'étais juste bluffé je
suis dit mais ça m'a tellement inspiré
tu me dis mais moi je veux être comme
lui la magie de huy devait d'offrir
cette paix aux autres de pour pouvoir
participer à ce monde plus en paix donc
j'étais complètement emballé et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me suis beaucoup
formé et que j'ai fait le choix après
d'être formatrice et aujourd'hui je suis
vraiment vraiment mais tellement
heureuse réalisé que mes relations n'ont
plus rien à voir
je vis cette qualité qui est beaucoup
plus profonde au cou plus dans la
connexion
tenez je vais vous raconter une anecdote
c'était l'année dernière exactement j'ai
animé à un module 1 de communication non
violente est l'une des stagiaires
étaient venus notamment parce que ses
collègues de boulot lui avait dit toi il
faudrait que tu ailles faire un stage de
cmv est en fait assez rapidement quand
elle est arrivée j'ai compris pourquoi
il disait ça en fait pendant ces deux
jours de formation
régulièrement elle n'interrompt pas pour
partager son avis mais surtout surtout
pour juger la façon dont j'animais est
également le contenu je me souviens à un
moment donné elle m'a dit oh là là mais
qu'est ce que t'es lente ou un autre
moment a dit me fait mouche ou à un
autre moment elle a commencé à dire oui
mais enfin tout ça c'est la théorie en
réalité ce pas réalisable un autre
moment est là elle a dit tout simplement
qu'elle voulait pas participer à
l'exercice voilà je vous passe les
détails c'était assez intense
alors c'est très très rare que ça arrive
et en même temps c'était ce qui était
vivant pour elle
alors voilà j'ai accueilli chacune de
ces interactions
en allant voilà repérer ces fameux
sentiment ces fameux besoin qu'elle nous
partageaient jusqu'à ce qu'elles vivent
suffisamment de compréhension d'empathie
pour cal son tour elle soit prête aussi
à écouter ce qui pouvait se jouer pour
moi également
et alors peu à peu
à chaque fois on a fait ça remet peu à
peu on trouver des solutions qui lui à l
kimaya moi qui aie à tout le groupe
alors je vous cache pas que quand le
module 2 est arrivée quelques mois après
je me suis dit bon je suis pas sûr
qu'elle se réinscrivent et j'ai été
hyper surprise voit son nom sur la liste
brand
elle arrive elle était métamorphosé
le visage hyper paisible pendant toute
la formation une attitude détendue
rien à voir personne n'en revenais est
en fait pendant la formation elle vient
me voir et me dit elodie il faut que je
te dise un truc je voudrais te remercier
pour pour la formation au module 1 et
surtout de partager quelque chose qui
s'est passé pour moi en fait deux jours
après la formation
j'ai pas compris ce qui s'est passé tout
a un coût je me suis ti en paix
elle m'a dit j'ai eu l'impression que
quelque chose avait complètement lâché
waouh quand elle m'a dit ça j'ai compris
pourquoi je la voyais métamorphosé et ça
m'a fait tellement chaud au cas rien de
vous leur partage et là c'est un nouveau
très très présent parce que je me rends
compte à quel point si je fais ça c est
également c'est pour ce plaisir que je
vis bien sûr de me relier h à 4 quel
qu'il soit mais fait aussi pour voir
cette joie à cette paix est vrai chez
l'autre cette transformation qui ont
alors voila si ça vous donne envie de
vivre des choses un petit peu similaire
je vous propose de vivre une petite
expérience expérience est la suivante je
vous parlais de ce fameux fil tout à
l'heure
le fils de l'humanité la prochaine fois
que vous rencontrez quelqu'un qui se
comporte diamétralement opposés à ce que
vous aimeriez
essayer de vous imaginer ce fils de
l'humanité qui vous relie
vous l'imaginez hockey
et je vous invite à vous poser la
question suivante pour vous y aider
c'est qu'elle est son besoin
quel est son besoin
quand elles se comportent comme cela
quand elle parle ainsi
à votre avis c'est pour nourrir quel
besoin ce que c'est un besoin d'amour
un besoin de sécurité
de partage
de légèreté tenez quand je vois une mère
dans la rue qui crie sur son enfant moi
je cautionne pas tu mal à l'aise avec ça
parce que j'ai envie que l'idée de la
bienveillance j'ai envie que du soin
qu'ils soient apportées du respect de
l'intégrité psychologique de l'amour
donc ne renie absolument pas le tragique
de la situation
et en même temps
je peux vraiment heureux liés à cette
mer par ce fils d'humanité en me posant
la question calé son besoin
je peux m'imaginer que peut-être qu'elle
se sent terriblement démunis parce
qu'elle aimerait tellement être entendu
par son enfant et cala un monde écoute
ou peut-être encore qu'elle est
tellement investi par son rôle de mère
qui veut transmettre quelque chose à son
enfant parce qu'elle aimerait être
assuré qu'il va s'en sortir dans la vie
qu'elle nourrit un besoin de
transmission un besoin de sécurité et
aussi pour elle alors vous voyez je peux
me relier
à cet être humain malgré nos choix
différents
alors voilà ce que je vous propose c'est
de vivre cette expérience
la prochaine fois ou pourquoi pas
plusieurs fois d'ailleurs que vous
imaginez la prochaine fois que vous
voyez quelqu'un qui se comporte
différemment de vous que vous ne vous
n'aimez pas son attitude allait essayer
essayer de mettre de côté ce juge qui
canalise qui est en train de juger
l'autre essayait
visualiser ce fils et posez vous la
question quel peut bien être son besoin
et si à force à force de vivre cette
expérience
vous sentez que peu à peu votre coeur
s'ouvre vous vous sentez plus en paix
alors bienvenue dans la communication
violente merci infiniment pour votre
écoute
[Applaudissements]